welcome back to the real rejects we're
fans of eric voss we're gonna watch
today
daredevil mcu plan kevin feige confirms
defenders crossover in marvel phase four
this is what i wanna hear i don't know
what the plan i don't know what eric
voss is gonna say i've always thought
they should just like
you know do a defenders movie might as
well hop right into it
but that's my wish that's my specific
wish let's see what eric boss has to say
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as one division launches
marvel's next era studio head kevin
feige is
opening up about his bigger plans
including
possibly reviving marvel netflix names
like
never say never jessica jones luke cage
and
god bless this man he did not rule it
out
which i think we can't count as i did
one small step by feige one giant leap
for fan conclusions i'm actually gonna
break down
exactly what kevin feige said because
he's been a real chatty cathy this week
and we gotta read the tea leaves but i'm
also gonna lay out the likeliest path
for if i need to reintroduce daredevil
in the titles we now know
to be in this updated
the netflix marvel heroes quote oh i
think i got to put on a hat because this
is fikey here
well you've certainly seen what we
announced at comic-con a year and a half
ago
and on disney investor day a few weeks
ago so that's our focus but
i've been at marvel long enough to never
say never about anything underlining you
better believe
it
oh darling well well done
iii he perhaps says peter parker's
defense attorney though unlike the other
spider-man three casting reports this
rumor has never been confirmed in fact
feige recently said
the fun thing about online speculation
when it comes to our stuff is how
sometimes it could
be more off the mark and sometimes it's
shockingly close
and that's held true for the last few
years but seeing which is which would
take all the fun out of everything
also never say never
like secret invasion fantastic four
blade so it's clear the guy
intends to get around to all of it
eventually so knowing that what is the
best way forward with all the titles we
know about
to introduce the netflix defenders
universe characters well a quick
reminder of
a movie that the mcu tends to walk one
of two paths with its titles
the bucky path or the rocket path the
bucky path to tell grounded stories
dealing with human institutions
the rocket path to tell cosmic stories
dealing with fantasy and sci-fi themes
these netflix marvel characters tend to
walk that bucky path right their street
level there are supernatural elements
but they rarely live in manhattan let
alone earth's atmosphere so let's start
with matt murdock daredevil where is he
going to show up in mcu some fans hope
that he will cameo in spider-man 3 as
peter parker's lawyer
i am less certain though that movie is
already looking
pretty stuffed and feige has made it
clear that the movie would go more in
the direction of the multiverse to
bridge with doctor strange too
and i don't know how much room will be
left over for peter parker's legal
troubles
i think it's more likely to see matt
murdock appear in an episode of
she-hulk our legal action comedy with 10
episodes giving plenty of episodic cases
that could tie into the firm of nelson
and murdoch or
any number of manhattan-based cases
which could include a mention of
kingpin wilson fisk or even a title
coming
sooner in the mcu phase four the falcon
the winter soldier is coming in just two
months and it is confirmed to visit the
fictional marvel setting of magipore
which not only has
ties to wolverine and the other mutants
but the country rests atop the head of a
giant dragon that in the comics gets
awakened by
the hand also connected to the world of
daredevil so
let's be on the lookout of hand
sightings not just hand sightings you
know
the hand sightings i gotta say i gotta
say i got pauses really quick pause it i
mean the idea of him
showing up in she-hulk would make a lot
of sense considering that
jennifer is a lawyer matt murdock as a
lawyer as well
and then what he just pointed out here
with falcon and the winter soldier
that would also make a lot of sense with
its times at the hand but the time to
the hand
yes was introduced with daredevil but it
was also with the defenders
overall i'm already thinking it's more
likely to it would make more sense for
it to be
she-hulk especially if they have like
you know they're they're going against
each other in court or something like
that
or they need consultation advice but
i might i might just have to say that
i think regardless putting him in one of
the shows would make a lot more sense
considering and especially if they do
bring back charlie cox himself
considering how daredevil was a series
yeah
but i would be a little bummed if he's
on spider-man but there are a lot of
other people in spider-man let's
continue it
this falcon winter soldier series
because that could be the door to
electra to stick no boo daredevil and to
iron fist and speaking of iron fist
everyone can favor him appearing in a
tournament roster for
shang chi in the legend of the ten rings
i made a video before how there are
a lot of warriors in the marvel world
who could appear on that lineup but
really the one i'm hoping for
is luke cage why well luke cage was
incarcerated at seagate
prison just off the coast of georgia
which is also where in the prime
mcu trevor slattery was held and justin
hammer before that agent of the ten
rings broke out slattery now jessica
jones she could show up in an episode of
she-hulk
dude i didn't even think about luke cage
and how that does
tie in that's right damn
you know you forget about those marvel
one shots
and they've tuna like that's i love that
those still turn out to be relevant
after so much time
and also even with um oh
yeah with the marvel one shot but also
with it being changing legitimate rings
not only is there a chance that luke
cage could appear but trevor slattery
could appear too
because of yes involvement with the team
yeah
so to speak oh damn
eric boss you're blowing my mind you're
blowing my mind i'm an investigator
but i would be more interested to see
her investigation skills show
up to suss out humans versus scrolls in
the secret invasion series because she
does undergo a squirrel swap
in those comics now let's not forget
punisher frank castle
a guy i hope we will see show up in moon
night
moon knight series will explore some
darker themes of mental illness of mark
specter dissociative identity disorder
and
maybe lay the groundwork for moon knight
and maybe the punisher to be part of an
mcu midnight sons team up with doctor
strange
will marvel handle the casting charlie
cox john berthold
wait wait wait wait wait oh we got a
bosses oh hey hold on a second
we'll run it back so don't miss it but
oh you know
with the fact that they are letting the
mcu deadpool
be rated r that opens up the door
for other movies to be rated r
absolutely right
and like if you have if you have blade
being rated r if you can't do punisher
without being rated r
this makes this midnight sun's crossover
feel that much more likely to
happen and i have thought too many like
i highly doubt disney plus would do moon
knight and go down a rated r path
with its own television series on disney
plus
but i'm loving the sound of this this
actually sounds great
and the mcu deadpool r rating
makes all this feel a lot more likely
feels a lot more likely
yeah because i mean it seems like with
that precedent
set if they prove that they have a
justifiable reason to
it makes me wonder about the previous
drafts of doctor strange too scott
derrickson was talking about how that
started out being like oh this is going
to be
harder core horror not rated r but
something harsher and that got reworked
i wonder if
maybe the original plan was to do that
disney didn't want to for some reason
and now
you know moving forward with all these
extra parts perhaps it is more possible
in a deadpool
r-rated mcu world to get some of these
harsher tones
and who knows maybe they can bring in
the 20th century label or just
keep it as marvel studios and distance
some of the disney bumpers or whatever
and
and find a way to make that work because
so many of the pieces are here and then
with dr strange being the the lead of it
and when the fact that multiverse and
madness is supposed to
be the main thing that's really going to
shake things up
this would be perfect oh damn we're
going to start getting some darker art
i don't know about art but for sure some
darker
it's a darker marvel for sure yeah
hey i mean i'm getting pumped man i'm
getting pumped good
judgment so i feel like they can take
the right lessons and make it work
all right team up with doctor strange
and blade
but how will marvel handle the casting
charlie cox john berthold kristen ritter
vincent and offering mike holter
i'm gonna be really bummed if any of
these names get recast but could
feige commit to bringing over all
could he even do that we're talking a
lot of actors a lot of them have moved
on with their careers
if you bring over one of them don't you
kind of have to bring over a lot of them
claire temple rosario dawson's now
i feel like most of them have not really
moved except for rosario dawson
all stand to appear here
i don't think it would be too hard like
most that moved on
especially being that they would start
rolling on this a while from now
oh man if you bring over one of them
don't you kind of have to bring over a
lot of them claire temple rosario
dawson's now in orange makeup elsewhere
on disney plus is ahsoka tano working
with john favreau who was also
foggy nelson in the past life come to
think and wouldn't it be kind of weird
for mike holter luke cage to meet
mahershala ali blade when that same face
used to be cornell stokes
it's kind of a mess right now i could
imagine some batshit multi
that is a good that's an excellent
that's a good point
especially because rehearsal but then
again
you know blade they can do a little bit
of things with his makeup to make him
look a tad
different a tad inhuman yeah and then
like
but the person who played maria hill was
in captain america civil war but she
wasn't she wasn't like a
like she's had a scene in civil war
whereas cotton mouth was like a
main character in season one of luke
cage so
i do see that but let's see what else he
has to say here
first explanation for how the mcu could
cross over some
marvel netflix actors but not others
like think about it with jk simmons
jamie foxx alfred molina clearly there's
some kind of plans to
explain how alt universe faces are now
just in the mcu
but again going to kevin feig use
carefully chosen words
we might be overthinking this he might
just use these upcoming titles to hint
at the existence of
elements from the netflix marvel world
would not yet commit to the characters
themselves cameoing yet
this would give his fans time to just
move on to new distractions and as much
as i hate it
he might recast no obviously even
afraid to do that and not just back in
phase one with hulk and rhodey
feige just swapped out emma furman
cassie lang from avengers end game with
catherine newton in ant-man the wasp
quantomania
and you all said nothing so let me know
what you want to happen with this
also you can support this channel by
checking out our new latest obsession
that is a swaggy jacket one division
themed it's got hidden easter eggs among
visions floating consciousness that you
can only find
the augmented reality on your phone how
did they design this i have no idea but
i am so excited to get mine meanwhile
epic hero shop has launched their own
companion shirt with wanda if you care
about keeping this unusual couple
together which you should
and this one also has a secret art
you can enter by subscribing to your
youtube channel epic hero labs and
filling out the form you'll find it at
thecarobshop.com subscribers there will
be
a new winner announced there's also a
bunch of ways to get more entries into
the giveaway at that website so go check
it out epic hero shop dot com
giveaway follow me at ea boss follow new
rock star subscribers here on youtube
thank you for watching
do it yourself too guys
i guess the last thing i'll add to to
all this is that when it comes to the
idea of getting new cast bringing back
some cast numbers i feel like it's just
a case-by-case basis
like yeah we didn't really say anything
about cassie lange but let's face
it most i think most of us
might not even really notice yeah like i
just don't feel like we we really would
um that's not an insult to that actress
i'm saying that
she had like a couple of moments yeah
and that has that character she mostly
goes to serve scott's character rather
than being her own character
yeah like it's not something that is
that huge and i feel it's like you do
bring jay jonah jameson back from
this raimi films into here so i really
think it's just more about the impact
the presence the iconography associated
with that character perhaps
versus recasting i feel like it's going
to be a case-by-case basis
and then i think the real answer will
come once we see
however they explain their multiverse
and the collisions of
universes smashing together and all that
that's really where i think most of our
answers lie
but as far as it goes i think this is a
really great video
it got me really excited for the
possibilities and it all lines up with a
lot of information that has been coming
out lately
so either way it looks like daredevil on
the horizon is not too far
off some capacity guys what do you think
about this
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click the notification bell if you
haven't subscribed new rockstars yet
do it hit that like button last but not
least
flev doran flev i just wanted to send
you
some love i love that you love the
blepham you
take the words away from my mouth and my
lips and you caused me to have to use my
wits to cover for that in this here
i love that you exist in our little
multiverse
and i also love your enthusiasm i'm glad
that you're with me for shows like
psych i'm glad that you're with me i've
seen you on even a couple music video
reactions and it always makes me happy
to know that you were there across the
world with a little love and a little
enthusiasm because it always brings my
day up so
you know i just hope you're doing well
and i hope the 2021 is off to a nice
start for you because it's been chaos
here
much love buddy thank you for everything
phleb i promise to respond to you
soon just playing some catch-up but i
will respond to your message really soon
love you buddy
[Music]